Silas Robertson — better known as Uncle
Si — has been entertaining people with his
quirks and hijinks since 2012, when he was
first featured on A&E's Duck Dynasty reality
series.
"I was a player before they even invented
the game, Jack."
Along with his ever-present iced tea glass,
he shot to household recognition and went
on to become the most popular person on the
show.
Uncle Si and his catchy sayings decorate many
a piece of Duck Dynasty merchandise, and he's
even received the coveted Chia Pet treatment.
However, Duck Dynasty ended in April of 2017,
and Robertson retired from working at Duck
Commander, the duck-call manufacturing business
featured on the show.
"Hey.
I gotta clear my head."
So where is Si Robertson today, and what keeps
him entertained ever since he left the immediate
national spotlight?
As it turns out, Uncle Si is a jack of all
trades when it comes to hobbies: he's tried
his hand at writing, music-making, and, of
course, viral video analysis, which he conducted
alongside his nephew Willie Robertson on his
short-lived spin-off series Going Si-Ral that
wrapped shortly before Duck Dynasty did.
Virtually the moment the show ended, Robertson
released a book in May 2017.
Entitled Si-renity: How I Stay Calm and Keep
the Faith, the book is something of a behind-the-scenes-slash-memoir
that looks back at his entire life, including
his time spent on the A&E reality show.
But this was actually Robertson's fourth published
book.
It came after Si-cology 1: Tales and Wisdom
from Duck Dynasty's Favorite Uncle and two
children's books, Uncle Si and The Christmas
Elf and Everything's Better with a Beard,
which features the entire Robertson clan.
Since then, Uncle Si has decided to lean full-tilt
into a music career by founding his own country
music group, Uncle Si and the Sicotics.
The band consists of Robertson, his daughter-in-law
Marsha Robertson, and celebrated singer-songwriter
Bridgette Tatum.
They recorded a single called "As Seen on
TV" in 2017, and subsequently released a self-titled
EP.
Before the end of Duck Dynasty — and at
what was arguably the apex of his mainstream
fame — Robertson expanded his reach on the
small-screen by appearing on the television
series Last Man Standing, playing a character
called Uncle Ray opposite Tim Allen in the
2013 episode "Back to School."
He also dabbled in feature films, landing
a small part in the 2015 Christian religion
film Faith of Our Fathers.
"Hey, this stuff is so good you'll punch your
momma."
He also lent his voice to narrate VeggieTales:
Merry Larry and the True Light of Christmas.
However, the bite of the acting bug didn't
have long-lasting effects — Robertson hasn't
stepped in front of the camera since Duck
Dynasty ended in 2017.
And it seems that won't change any time soon,
as his focus is on Uncle Si and the Sicotics.
Robertson explained in a May 2018 interview
with Pop Culture that he had grown accustomed
to a certain way of life during the heyday
of Duck Dynasty, but he isn't about to let
a lack of riches keep him from a career in
music — something he had previously attempted
in 2014 with the release of his EP Me and
My Smokin' Hot Honey.
He explained,
"I got to start making me some money somewhere.
But I just chose the wrong industry to really
make a lot of money.
I think there's a lot of goals that we want
to meet as a band.
I would love to see that we finish this record
out, because I would love to see what we could
write beyond what we've got.
I think everybody believes it to be just this
funny thing, and there's a lot of that on
there.
But there's also some moments that happen
on there that are really important, and I
would love just to be able to have the opportunity
that we can all write together some more and
see how deep we can go."
Finishing a full-length album is the band's
current priority, as Uncle Si and the Sicotics
are no longer actively touring the country.
If you want to keep tabs on them, they regularly
post videos on their Facebook page.
Even though Duck Dynasty is over, Si Robertson's
life clearly hasn't stopped for a second.
"Hey, when they say they don't know what hit
em, that's because it was me that hit em."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.